[موسيقى]
طراز بيت وداد قعوان للثوب العربي هو
عباره عن مركز اسسنا لاحتواء مجموعه
الوالده الخاصه هي قضت حوالي 50 سنه من
حياتها بتجامع الاثواب التقليديه من
فلسطين ومن الاردن ومن سوريا ومن بلدان
عربيه اخرى
فتاسسنا هون 2014 كمان
[موسيقى]
الوالده وداد قعوار هي اصلها او تربت
بمدينه بيت لحم وطبعا طوبه لحم جميل جدا
فاظن هي من صغرها كان عندها هيك يجذبها
الثوب الفلسطيني لما تخرجت من المدرسه كان
رجعت على بلدها كانت بمدرسه داخله رجعت
عملتها لقت في في حقيقه مختلفه لقت بلد
مختلفه لقت لاجئين اثر فيها كثير هذا
الشيء
واظلني كرده فعل صارت تشتري تواب اتجمع
تواب ما بعرف شغف فتحت عيونها لقت انه
بالاردن
ما كان في وعي لا للتراث التراث اللباس
وكان في تمدن سريع جدا فصارت تجمع وتجيب
معلومات كمان عن الدراسه الاردني بنفس
الشغف اللي كانت تجمع فيه عن التراث
الفلسطيني
[موسيقى]
هاي الطاوله بتفرجي باختصار
التنوع الموجود بين الاردن وفلسطين فمثلا
هو الاردن في عنا من الشمال للجنوب
وبفلسطين من الشمال للجنوب بفرجي قصات
الثوب المختلفه انواع الاقمشه المختلفه
اسماء
الغرزات المختلفه
[موسيقى]
ثوب الفلسطيني بالتحديد في تنوع كبير يعني
انا هلا هون واقفه جنب التوب رام الله
اللي هو مميز بالتطريز الاحمر مع
القماش الكتان البيج والصفه هاي اللي
بتحطها الست على راسها هون انا رح امشي
على توب بيت لحم
كمان منلاقي مختلف كثير مميز جدا
الحياكه هي كانت تسير بمدينه بيت لحم من
عائلات مميزه يعني اذا بتطلعوا هون هاي
الخيوط والالوان
البديعه التصميم
[موسيقى]
القسم هون هو
المفرق الرمثا واربد وجرش وعجلون والقطبه
الاردنيه بتتميز عن كل القطب يعني مش
موجوده بمحل ثاني بالمره اسمها الرقمه
اللي هي زي اكنه بطرزوا وبعدين بفرغوا او
بطرسوا وبيلفوا الخيط وبحطوا الالوان
[موسيقى]
والدتي كانت تجمع الاردني والفلسطيني
مباشره من النساء
ولها علاقات اجتماعيه بالبلدين لكن سوريا
كانت مختلفه فقررنا نعمل هذا المعرض فكان
يعني دراسه لالنا وصلنا نحكي مع اصدقاء
سوريين وسوريات يعطونا معلومات مختلفه هون
مثلا هذول التواب ونتواب السخنه اللي هم
بجنوب شرق سوريا
هدول منطقه القلمون اللي هن ضواحي
ضواحي دمشق
هدول هم منطقه حلب وادلب
[موسيقى]
هدفنا بطراز المحافظه على على صحه الاقمشه
وتوثيقها توثيقها الكترونيا على اساس انه
اي يوم هاي المعلومات مش موجوده او اي شخص
بده يحصل على هاي المعلومه يفتح الويب
سايت تبع طراز ويلاقي هاي المعلومات
[موسيقى]